[Music]
the heartbeat of New York has always
been the throbbing energy of its street
life and its people restless and
striving ready for anything
but for the past eight weeks the city
that never sleeps
has been anesthetized even in Times
Square
almost nothing moving except the screens
they call this the crossroads of the
world of course tens of thousands of
people pass through here on a typical
day
but these days you're lucky to find a
handful I think the soul of the city
thrives on density Valerie Paley is
chief historian at the now-closed
New York Historical Society is there a
precedent for this nothing quite like
this that's shut down the whole city and
affected just the whole temperament of
the city
a century ago during the pandemic of
1918 Spanish influenza gripped the city
facemasks were mandated by the Board of
Health papers
tracked the rising daily death toll then
- and the city's health commissioner dr.
Royal Copeland launched an anti spitting
crusade in fact there were Boy Scouts
who were deployed so if someone would
spit on the street they would give them
a little card that said you're in
violation of your city's code by
spitting it helped 20,000 died but New
York fared better than most major cities
and it never closed
in recent weeks I've wandered the city
where I was born
taking pictures I didn't know what else
to do
the scenes were both beautiful and
heartbreaking this is one of the places
I used to play when I was a kid the
Alice in Wonderland statue we used to
love to sit on top of the Mad Hatter's
hat
it opened in 1959 when I was three just
about when I started to climb in the
first few weeks of social distancing I
was started to catch a couple kissing
here it felt
illicit at first then hopeful the
cultural life of the city has been in a
kind of medically induced coma this is
the Broadway show company they just
started previous when Broadway was
suspended so they closed really before
they could even open the Metropolitan
Museum of Art the country's largest
museum would typically have up to 20,000
visitors a day this time of year
today it's 2-2 unique
Daniel Weiss is president and CEO of the
Met has it ever been like this before
we've closed in moments of crisis and
snowstorms and 9/11 for a few days but
never like this
what's it like to walk through this
place being in charge of it I've got to
say in this moment it's it's very eerie
to walk through the museum in the middle
of the day the light shining through the
windows and the objects looking
magnificent and no one in there total
silence just me is a not entirely a
comfortable feeling
why says the earliest the museum will
reopen is July but likely later
are you expecting when you do reopen
that things will go back to normal
quickly no my own sense is that we'll
never see that normal again
what do you think something like this
does to the soul of the city it's a
wonderful contemplative moment in a way
if you can find a silver lining to this
time and we wind up appreciating what
we're missing I think even more walking
through New York I've wondered what
we'll remember most about this moment
years from now I hope it's this the
beautiful noise that sweeps across
apartment blocks and intersections every
evening at the stroke of 7:00 a tribute
to health care workers the heroes who
fought the virus but also a tribute to
New York's own abiding spirit the sound
of a nearly 400 year old Sydney
determined to in doing this city really
does know how to survive the city
thrives on reinvention and resilience
it's bound to survive